hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
hi I'm John Humphrey we are going to
watch from looper one of the best
channels ever the most bizarre films
coming out in 2020
I love covering loopers videos they
usually give us plenty to talk about I
saw that this video was trending and I
rarely see looper trending on the
trending page of the trenders so I
thought his Avengers buds in for some
furry friends to a 21st century taken of
buzz where the horror classic these are
just some of the most surprising
unexpected and straight-up as our movies
hitting theaters in 2020 doctor Giulio
is a character with a weird history the
physician who could talking apples was
created by author Hugh lofting and
letters written home to his children
from the trenches of World War one
popular children's books in Victorian
England and back to the 1998 movies
starring Eddie Murphy which became
something of a franchise all its own
spawning such intriguingly title
directed DVD sequels as tail to the
chief returning to the big screen in the
form of Robert Downey jr. jr. I love
their voice maybe our DJ just need to
lighten things up a little bit it is a
destiny of all horror franchises to be
Jordan if he lets produce pretty much
the entire 21st century so far since the
dawn of the new millennium we've seen
remakes and
imaginings of The Texas Chainsaw
Massacre Nightmare on Elm Street Friday
the 13th and multiple steps pun intended
and a new Halloween
[Music]
another long dormant series seems ready
for similar treatment Candyman released
in 1992 was based on a story by
Hellraiser creator Clive Barker and star
Tony Todd is a supernatural killer who
hunted a housing project in Chicago and
represented the specter of racial
inequality
[Music]
Bloody Disgusting reported the film
directed by up-and-comer near DeCosta
will be a spiritual sequel that returns
to the now gentrified neighborhood of
the original kasi remains unannounced
that's angling to be involved in some
capacity come on Tony
one of the most intriguing 20:18 was the
launch of Sony's new generation of all
is live action Peter Parker's the MCU
this to be my set up to keep their own
stinking Spidey brand alive with the
slightest animated titles the first two
examples them and into the spider-verse
that they were released for Morbius
starting to cool living vampire who is
faced off with spider-man and comics
since the seventies no we didn't see
that one coming either
Daniel direct with the script by Dracula
untold riders now Alomar and surplice
Jared Leto will star as the titular
bloodsucker with former Doctor Who actor
Matt Smith appearing in a major role in
true detective Sarah Adria Arjona as
love interest or team Bancroft well
she's gonna be important it was released
in 1988 Murphy who covered the story
stars
a keen heir to the throne the fictional
African nation of Zamunda range marriage
and find a free-thinking bride to fall
in love with he travels to New York City
with trusted aide semi-successful decade
for Murphy after a period of Brewers and
rumblings that coming to America Segal
has been officially announced to be
released in 2020 what about Billa two
three Hakeem is coming back to America
after 30 years and this time searching
for his long-lost son original
supporting players are coming the
director share from the original movies
John Landis not only are adults stories
in seems super Tim Burton Wes Anderson
and Danny DeVito's name few 20/20
Walker's in mecca's will join that
lineup with the new take on the witches
this 1983 to ourselves tells the story
of an orphan boy who goes to live with
his grandmother in Surrey that's going
to be all CGI
never mind might not be thought Bill and
Ted three was coming you guys see Keanu
Reaves announcement breeze like well
easily the one I'm most excited for is
dr. Dolittle I mean Robert Downey jr.
taken over that's what we need and all
those voices especially after playing
Tony Stark for so long I'm just really
happy he's gonna really throw himself
into a brand new character new role you
know go in depth and his relationship
with spider-man is gonna continue with
Tom hauling it in there so easy to
promote movies that have boys overs in
it you just get a bunch of famous people
you see all their famous names and on
the trailers and the posters and you go
wow I love all those famous people I
want to hear them all talk and they
probably weren't in the same room when
they were doing this but I'm sure it's
gonna be a lot but maybe forget all
those professional voice actors who only
do this well Robert Downey jr. doesn't
do a whole lot of movies he needs
another solid franchise and what better
than going to the Doolittle we had too
many white people playing dr. Doolittle
then we got Eddie Murphy and we're like
no nevermind let's get back to a white
guy real rejects is political now who I
hate politics in my art how dare you
socialism sucks yeah like dr. Doolittle
sounds like an idea I heard it was super
expensive that's what I heard that's
very expensive I hope they go for
photorealism
yes I'm sure it'll be fun I mean 29 year
old men are the demographic for it so
hopefully it'll satisfy the people
Morbius I definitely talked about this
at least a few times on this channel
yeah they made venom work for the most
part I've enjoyed venom for what oh wow
I don't imagine Jared Leto saving
Morbius the way Tom Hardy was able to
but I am
Kure I mean like I really like the idea
of going out and making just other sort
of left-of-centre movies about villains
or other things to like in that sounds
I'm excited by what Sony Michael trying
to do hopefully they commit to some type
of gothic horror movie since this is a
vampire character that's what I'm hoping
for I feel like it's easy to be positive
or cynical about that movie kind of just
in-between right now yeah you know I
mostly just want to see what it looks
like and I'll continue until then being
bummed out that Sam Raimi never got to
do that at spider-man 4 that's why I say
about every villain that gets to make an
appearance in any of the spider-man
movies now Sam Raimi didn't get to put
him in spirit but he wanted the Prowler
was it as fuzzy for me it's the lizard
and Morbius cuz he actually wanted to do
this
Candyman with Jordan Peele producing
that's gonna be that's gonna be the main
selling point he's gonna be the next
person who gets the credit for directing
a movie it's gonna be is gonna be the
Phil Lord and Chris Miller or the Tim
Burton but they brought up the whole
gentrification idea taking some type of
like social political commentary and
fuse within its landscape of the film to
me that sounded cool I saw a Candyman
when I was very young I used to have the
monster channel and it just came all one
day I really enjoyed it was really
creepy I'm not yet at the point where if
I hear Jordan Peele produced you know
the way they like slap on James Bond's
name on war movies I'm not yet at that
point where I am a hundred percent sold
yet just because I can't really think of
properties or it it's like Jordan pee
like black Klansmen it wasn't really
advertised like that there was a spike
Lee joint you know but I feel like this
will be that movie where the main pushes
produce by Jordan Peele yeah this is
probably the one I'm most excited about
from this list because Candyman is
another horror movie that has some
pretty rich lower at the core of it I
really like the original movie and the
original movie has a sort of
socio-economic allegory on its mind and
so yeah coming back years later I feel
like especially now is a great time for
a new Candyman and yeah if we're
tackling the ideas of gentrification I
mean there's already some of that stuff
at play in the original film so I think
that's a great idea actually and I hope
they get Tony ty would you say it has a
core
Laur yeah I would say it has a core law
I heard him kind of run thanks to many
many sentences ago and finally gotta say
it was it a chore waiting for a good
moment to slip that in there I'm a
horror for puns yeah there we go there
we go and speaking of puns coming to
America or coming back I was gonna say
that's what I would have called it I
think you got to bring back Samuel
Jackson the character I really really
really hope the great Easter Egg to have
in there I don't have nostalgia for
coming to America
I already live here I already live here
it's great where's coach through the
world I'm not excited for this movie I'm
not but I'm really happy for those that
are very excited for it Eddie Murphy did
not get it do his follow-up to dr.
Doolittle he's doing coming back to
America hey Eddie Murphy could use a
boost I feel like he's been in a weird
place for a long time yeah so I would
love to see Eddie Murphy rekindle his
old glory days again that's all we can
say on that one too which is I've
actually never seen this movie that was
my first time seeing footage of that
that looked terrifying is pretty they
said there were as a Doug Benson effects
no cheese yes yes perfect
Doug Benson is all over there oh yeah
the creepy side remains yeah yeah yeah
totally I grew up with the book in the
audio book and then I watched the movie
at a young age and and yeah it
definitely creeped me out then and I've
always remembered it and I had no idea
of everything on this list this was the
one I had no idea was happening in
Robert Zemeckis his hands I'm very
curious to see how it'll turn out
but why dude it's gonna be great man Oh
totally
definitely definitely I don't know what
I was thinking of there I you know what
maybe I was thinking of a different
Robert dude he made delete the weapon
movies all of them yeah he made reindeer
games
definitely that's that director uh-huh I
was trying to think of like other
Roberts my concern with the movie is
that it'll go CGI when clearly what they
show there was some very creepy
great-looking practical effects with
Robert Zemeckis has made hey I'm likely
to believe he's gonna go down that this
will be live action you know so it's not
gonna be his Polar Express or his doctor
a goose what the hell is that Tim every
cost all that character is named Scrooge
its current image but it's a Guillermo
del Toro's gonna be producing and they
might do practical because I know
Guillermo del Toro the Pacific Rim is
pretty much you know he tries to infuse
practical as much as possible and I'm
sure it'll have that note binge watch
all these flicks the same day same day
man do it guys which one are you most
excited for it's coming out in 2020
didn't do any MCU movies I know it's not
one of the weird ones you guys can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification Bell check us on patreon we
got [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] and you can [ __ ]
too it's healthy to have at least three
bowel movements a day if you're a male
and none ever if you're a female